hey this is Mel strong and in this
lecture we're going to talk about
seasonal changes that occur in Earth's
atmospheric circulation pattern so we're
making the transition from weather to
climate and we haven't really talked
about the difference between weather and
climate yet so we're going to start with
that so weather is what we've been
talking about so far in this class is
what's happening right now in the
atmosphere it's the current conditions
okay
now weather turns out you can't really
predict it more than about five days out
and we probably never will and the
reason for that is something called
chaos that's in the atmosphere now chaos
is a mathematical thing but you can kind
of think of it as if you have a system
is so complicated that there are too
many variables we call those degrees of
freedom and all these extra degrees of
freedom mean that you can't really make
predictions very far out in time so what
will happen is a very small change
somewhere in the atmosphere can
propagate to a much bigger change that's
unforeseeable a few days in the future
mathematically is a pretty complicated
thing but you can kind of get a sense of
it with this movie that we saw before so
this is water vapor in the atmosphere
and in the bright white are clouds and
so we so if you just if I took a
freeze-frame of this right and I asked
you okay based on all the swirls and
everything you see what would this look
like say five days in the future it's
nearly impossible to do okay there are
so much going on here there's a lot of
chaos and so that means it's really
impossible to predict out more than five
days some outlets let's just say oh I
don't know The Weather Channel will
claim that they can make predictions
beyond what they do a 10-day forecast
but if you keep track of how well
they're doing and their ten-day forecast
is actually pretty bad okay
so realistically five maybe seven days
so that's weather climate climate really
refers to the average conditions for a
given place at a given time so in other
words we might say okay what high
temperature do we expect in Albuquerque
on July 1st so the answer to that we
would go back to all the July firsts
that we have on record in average the
high temperatures okay that's climate
and it can include all kinds of things
the high temperature the low temperature
the average temperature the
precipitation the dew point is a lot of
things that we can include in climate
now the weird thing is that climate is
actually predictable for decades out so
it would be impossible for us to say
exactly what's going to happen
September 15th of next year in terms of
the weather we just can't do that that's
impossible
but what we can do is we can say say 10
years or 20 years in the future what
will a average September month be like
how will it be compared to an average
September this year right that's the
kind of thing that we're that we do with
climate so how is this possible
well there's one little analogy I do
that might help imagine if you have a
cigarette and the cigarettes burning and
it has all these wispy curls of smoke
that come up alright and I take a
picture of that and I say okay tell me
exactly where that all these little
smoke particles are going to be in five
seconds from now okay that would be very
hard to do there's too many degrees of
freedoms too much chaos in this system
that's whether climate would be okay now
we're going to take our cigarette and my
question is where do you expect the
smoke to be say five seconds from now
and climate would say well all the smoke
is going to be contained in this volume
right there that's sort of the
difference between
in climate weather is concerned about
where are the individual particles of
smoke going to be climate is concerned
with well where is all the smoke gun to
be contained sometimes we were referred
to this as the boundary conditions so
for any given place there are
limitations I can only get so hot and
only gets so cold there's only a certain
amount of water vapor you expect in the
air these are the boundary conditions
and they're set by all kinds of things
like the atmospheric chemistry and the
tilt of the Earth's axis and what the
Sun is doing all these different things
okay so that's climate you can actually
make a better prediction for climate
decades out then you can with weather
more than about a week out there's
another term that you will sometimes
hear called a climate normal or
sometimes we just say a climate norm
climate normal is climate data for a
thirty-year period and it came about
because a long time ago there's a bunch
of scientists at the weather meeting and
really reliable weather stations had
only been around for about 30 years and
so they decided to use a 30-year chunk
of time to represent climate and every
so many years they redefined that
30-year chunk so sometimes when you look
up climate conditions for a certain
place like back to my example what's the
average high temperature for July 1st in
Albuquerque it usually the number you
might find if you look something like
that up will come from a 30-year chunk
of time called a climate normal okay so
we'll see these in this class okay first
things first why do we have seasons so
if you ask a lot of people including
college graduates why is it warmer in
the summer and colder in the winter the
most common wrong answer that you will
get is that the earth is closer to the
Sun in the summer and farther from the
Sun in the winter and kids believe this
Adil's believe this Yale graduates
believe this okay so let's just go over
this first the reason we have seasons is
because the earth is on a tilted axis
now this orbit looks like an ellipse but
it's actually pretty close to a circle
now if we move around the Sun okay with
time so let's say here here I am in June
and what you can see is that if you
lived up above this little red circle
the Arctic Circle that you are in Sun 24
hours a day right and if you have
somewhere down here you have part of
your day of Sun part of your day as
night and if you're down here which we
can't see right now they're in the dark
24 hours a day so I'm gonna show that
okay this is just another view of the
same thing here's these guys down here
in Antarctica
they'd aren't seeing any Sun whatsoever
right so right now the northern
hemisphere is getting more Sun southern
hemisphere is getting less Sun okay so
it's our summer and it's their winter
all right so if we travel forward in
time we come around and as we go around
the Sun we're maintaining this tilted
angle right the angle of rotation of the
earth and Earth's axis it's not exactly
perpendicular to the plane there the
orbits it's tilted a little bit about 23
degrees and that's why this is happening
so I come over here now we're in the
we're in the winter our winter and you
can see that the guys that are in the
Arctic Circle and any for any place
north of that are in the dark 24 hours a
day and if we can see what our friends
in Antarctica are doing they are in the
Sun 24 hours a day so our winter their
summer okay but it's not the distance
right the distant fact in the northern
hemisphere our summer were actually
farthest from the Sun in the summer and
we're actually closest to the Sun in the
winter for us in the northern hemisphere
alright so with that let's talk about
what the seasons actually do as a result
of this tilted Earth's axis business we
alternate between heating the Northern
Hemisphere and and then heating the
southern hemisphere right so here's a
little animation it says net shortwave
radiation that's a kind of a fancy way
of just saying sunlight so just imagine
that this is showing you how much
sunlight hits the ground as the months
go by okay and you see there's this band
of dark red which is the most intense
sunlight and it migrates north and it
migrated south with the seasons now it's
not a perfect band it's kind of spotty
because it also takes into account
clouds so this is how much radiation
actually hits the surface which if
there's a lot of clouds it will reflect
some of that so that's why it's not a
perfect band but a couple things to
think about here first of all when we're
in we have the winter up here right they
have the summer down there paid
hopefully you know that but some people
don't what would life be like if you
lived right out here say where my dot is
right now so this would be kind of weird
because the red band passes you over
there and you have summer and then it
comes back down and passes you again and
you have summer again so if you lived
along the ITCZ that area you actually
would have two summers you don't really
have anything you could consider winter
or even seasons for that matter but you
have two extra hot periods of the year
if you live near the equator well if the
earth was all the same thing
then the patterns of temperature would
kind of follow that last animation but
it's not all the same thing
and so this what we're looking at here
is air temperature again throughout the
months and you can see that there's a
band here of high air temperatures and
then you can see the the
we purple colors are the cold
temperatures so a couple things of
notice when it becomes the winter say
our winter the continents cool off much
quicker than the oceans right so you can
see that and in the summer the
continents heat up faster than the
oceans so we talk about sometimes this
term heat capacity that it takes a lot
of energy to heat up water and then once
water is warm it takes a long time for
it to cool off whereas soil heats up
pretty quickly cools off pretty quickly
so the temperatures of the continents
change much more rapidly than the
temperatures of the oceans so that's one
thing to notice another thing to notice
is that the really if we're thinking
about the ITCZ so again this is a
continuation of the last lecture so if
you didn't watch the last one go back
and do that first or nothing is going to
make sense here the ITCZ follows the
hottest part of the earth okay but the
hottest part of the earth is moving
great so if you imagine kind of right in
the middle of this orange blob kind of
right up in North Africa down here right
so as you watch this the ITCZ is going
to follow the hottest part of the earth
so it's also moving with this orange
blob here so as the seasons change the
location of the ITCZ changes well
remember at the ITCZ that's where it
rises okay well if you change where air
rises then you're also going to change
where the air comes and sinks back down
so what's not shown here but we'll see
in a second is locations of the
subtropical highs also change with the
seasons
so what we're getting into is a pattern
you know many patterns here they're
going to be shifting with the seasons
the ITCZ
the heavily cells subtropical highs
polar fronts easterlies westerlies all
that all that stuff it's all going to
shift with the seasons as we
alternatively warm in cool different
parts of the earth
okay so here is an animation that kind
of shows how some of these things change
with the seasons so right now I've got
time slider down here and it's said
early January and I can see that the
ITCZ is this purple line right here and
the first thing you'll notice is that
it's actually not a straight line and if
you remember from the previous lecture
we looked at some diagrams from a
textbook that showed the ITCZ is as nice
perfectly straight line usually right at
the equator and we see that you know it
hits the equator a couple of places here
but it's not at the equator so right now
we're in the winter and so the winter is
heating up the southern hemisphere more
which means that these continents down
here are heating up more which means
that the warmest part of the earth is
kind of near the equator but right now
South America is is warming up quite a
bit because it's their summer so you see
it dip down to the south a little bit
then returns close to the equator then
again Africa is warming up because it's
it's summer and it dips down again and
then it gets into some really warm ocean
water which we'll talk about probably in
a couple of lectures now here it shows
the Hadley cells this is where the air
is rising and you can see they show the
air moving to the north and the south
and sinking down about 30 degrees north
30 degrees south and of course that
travels all the way across you know the
world right so this is going all the way
around the planet they also show in here
the polar front now this is kind of a
weird way to show it because the polar
front itself is a wavy line kind of like
the Purple Line and it would be coming
along kind of through here right and it
changes day to day right it's always
changing though with a bunch of these
rows be waves okay so I'm going to move
forward in time and so as I do so we're
getting into our spring and then we're
getting into our summer and you notice
how this whole thing is migrating
northwards right and as it migrates
northwards the Hadley cells also migrate
northwards and polar front migrates more
northwards so I continue to move this oh
we just got past summer they were going
to get into fall and you'll see the ITCZ
who is back down down meaning south
right okay so this is how the ITCZ
changes with the seasons and heavily
sells change with it which means that
we're that air is coming down right here
that's where that subtropical high is
gonna be it's also going to change so I
want to show pressure that's what that
button does okay so let's see if we can
figure out what's happening here so I'm
gonna go back to January and we've got
our subtropical highs there's a strong
one right there one right there one
right there about 30 degrees right more
or less 30 degrees
then we've got some over here and here
those are about 30 degrees we also have
some highs if you remember back when we
talked about air pressure we said that
you could get a high pressure if you
have just really cold air that's what's
happening here
so our friends over here in Siberia
which are very cold they're experiencing
some high pressure just from a big pool
of cold air as our friends in the
northern territories up here in Canada
very cold air makes a high pressure for
a totally different reason also we can
see lows here and here these are places
where mid-latitude cyclones often form
we didn't talk about this when we talked
about mid-latitude cyclones but there's
certain places on earth where they
happen to form over and over the
conditions are just right and this is
referred to as the Aleutian low it's a
so these are the Aleutian Islands and
it's just a place where these mid
latitudes start to spin up and we talked
about the stages that they go through
well they start here so it's low because
on average this is where you often get
the warm fronts and the cold fronts over
and over and over and over right you can
give them other places but if you
average it out over many years you would
see it kind of there's a low pressure
that kind of hangs out over here and one
over here okay also one other thing
looks like we have a thermal glow right
here so it's super hot in Africa hot air
rises so they put a low well here okay
notice
this one this is the Pacific subtropical
high oK we've talked about this last
time it's sitting out here in the ocean
I'm going to go forward in a time and
notice what it in particular does so as
we go forward in time our lows that we
had up here from the mid-latitude
cyclones are going away there's still
mid-latitude cyclones but they're
they're pretty weak and they're really
far to the north but notice what's
happened to our Pacific subtropical high
it's getting bigger which means it's
getting stronger but it's also moving
away from the continent okay so here we
are in in July and we see it's kind of
parked out here over the Pacific and
it's big right let me go back I go back
in our winter it's smaller but it's
actually much closer to us me New Mexico
Southern California Arizona much closer
to that area and in the summer he gets
bigger but it kind of moves further
offshore okay so this is important
because what we're leading up to is
we're trying to explain weather patterns
climate patterns that we see in the
United States so one of the climate
patterns that we see in New Mexico and
in Arizona and in Southern California is
that we have pretty dry winters right in
New Mexico most of our precipitation
falls in the monsoon season in the
summer and then the other half of it is
scattered throughout the year so we have
pretty dry
January's pretty JA dried December is
pretty dry February's and that's because
this Pacific subtropical high is just
sitting right up there really close to
us so even though it's weaker it's
closer and we if we feel the effects of
that Pacific subtropical high now in the
summer it gets bigger it gets stronger
and it but it moves further away from us
so we get a relief from the Pacific
subtropical high and that is one of the
things that allows our monsoon to
actually kick in and start producing
precipitation but
not to clear on this but it actually is
closer to the west coast up here like
California Oregon and Washington State
so their summers are actually going to
be really really dry because of the
specific subtropical high it's it's out
there right off the coast and they are
under the influence of sinking air day
after day after day so we can see this
on earth nil Schoolnet and you can
actually change the date and look at
different times in the past so what I've
done here is I've loaded up a day that's
in January and we're looking at surface
winds and I'm actually going to change
the overlay to MSL P 4 means sea level
pressure and right there spiraling off
the west coast so there is California
there's roughly the international border
and there's the Pacific subtropical high
it's spiraling around really pretty
close to where we live right and you can
see the winds coming right down the
coast here now I'm gonna I'm gonna
change I'm gonna go one day further now
you can see it's even closer right so
that would mean even more sinking air
kind of in this region one day there it
is again
so as I go day to day you'll see it
moves around a little bit but it's
pretty much just staying in this one
spot producing sinking air and that
seeking air is gonna fight cloud
formation and we have clear skies for
most of the days of the winter now
before we change the season let me just
point out that these are mid-latitude
cyclones that's what these guys are
right so those guys are going to come
ashore and they're going to slam into
the west coast north of the Pacific
subtropical high so you can kind of
think of it like the Pacific subtropical
high is kind of blocking the storms from
coming in and sometimes they'll talk
about that in in weather reports that
the high has blocking the low it's not
quite how it works but you can think of
it that way okay so now let's change
from a winter day to a summer day okay
so same thing I'm
going to change to see the level
pressure and now that big white blog
there is the Pacific subtropical high so
here we are down here notice how much
bigger it is zoom in a little bit so by
comparison the one we saw last time was
kind of like about that big this thing
is giant and so we saw that in the
animation that the Pacific Pacific
subtropical high gets larger in the
summer in our summer and it moves out
into the Pacific Ocean away from arc
where we live kind of far from the coast
but notice that these winds are coming
right down the west coast right here
alright so we are farther from it than
we were in the winter but these guys are
actually under a pretty strong influence
of the Pacific subtropical high so
they're getting sinking air all the way
up and down the coast so we call this
Mediterranean climate Mediterranean
climate name from the Mediterranean Sea
is a place where you typically have wet
winters and dry summers west coast of
the United States super dry summers if
you look at say rain records for like
San Francisco I mean there's like 30
year periods with no recorded
precipitation in the summer okay super
dry because of the specifics of tropical
high so if the ITCZ is moving and the
Headlee cells are moving and subtropical
hinds are moving and the polar fronts
are moving what we get are moving
patterns of precipitation throughout the
year so this animation is showing
monthly averages of precipitation so
what they what they've done is for each
one of these months they've gone back 30
years and looked at all the
precipitation that fell around the world
and plotted it and as you might expect
the darker blue colors mean more
precipitation so this one is in
millimeters so dark blue 400 millimeters
of precipitation for that month now one
of the things that you notice at first
is that you've got this dark blue right
through here
that's the
zone of most precipitation is following
pretty closely the ITCZ so as the ITCZ
migrates north and south
this blue stripe migrates north and
south with it okay so a lot of rain is
falling along the ITCZ they have these
gigantic cumulonimbus every day the
other thing you might notice is that we
have these white areas and white means
no precipitation so if we remember from
last lecture we talked about how the
subtropical highs in theory would form a
stripe all the way around you know a
band all the way around the earth if the
earth was all the same thing I could
pose all water but the fact that you
have continents breaks that up and you
can see that here so here's a
subtropical high here's a subtropical
high here's a subtropical high and in
between there are some wet zones right
so it doesn't really form this this
continuous band because of the
continents kind of miss this up but you
can definitely see the effect of the
subtropical highest these are areas
where it literally may not rain for
weeks and weeks at a time now this one
in particular is the one that we are
interested in this is the Pacific
subtropical high so notice that it grows
into the summer and then it shrinks
again in the winter and in migrants
north and south a little bit right so we
just saw this but here it is growing out
into the summer out into the ocean then
kind of shrinks back point is it's
closer to us in the winter even though
it's smaller another thing you might
notice overall most of the rain falls in
the ocean okay you mean I thought about
that before but there's a lot of white
out here in the continents because once
storms leave the ocean they don't have a
source of moisture so that rain out
effect rain shadow effect all happens
and you see big areas out here in the
continents you know I hear it as in the
winter really dry out there remember
cold air dry air so in the winter
evening you might have a really big
storm it doesn't have them
much moisture so you see really dry out
you know areas up here say in a little
sorry in Canada in Siberia in the winter
months it looks pretty white they get
very little precipitation so most of the
rainfall falls in the ocean so we're
gonna go through month by month what the
precipitation patterns are like in the
United States so each one of these maps
I'm going to show you is a 30 year
normal so again that means we've taken
records for 30 years and we're gonna use
that record to determine the averages
the colors represent how much
precipitation fell in this particular
months on this case this is the January
so let's look at this and we're going to
concentrate on different areas of the
country at a time in let's look at the
west coast here so we've got a lot of
precipitation hitting the west coast
those are those mid-latitude cyclones
coming in right if you can see once they
pass through now the colors indicate a
lot less precipitation that's our rain
shadow effect and then they pass over
here and really dry and we talked about
this last time how they have gone over
these mountains and they go through the
Rockies and then they come down this
eastern slope and there's not much
precipitation left and the air is going
downhill and all those things fight
storm formation so we also said last
time that once you get a low-pressure
Center out here the mid-latitude
cyclones come through this way they can
pick up more moisture and they're
re-energized and they produce more
precipitation so you see a lot of
precipitation down here also in January
and that's all mostly from these
mid-latitude cyclones that they run out
of gas down here but then they pick it
up again over there also significant
amount of precipitation up here in the
Northeast ok so we see a pattern that's
very similar to that we go to the
February and notice what happens as I
move into March and in April I start to
see that the wet area is shrinking
towards the north on the west coast and
that's because our mid-latitude cyclones
are
moving further and further to the north
until eventually we get to June and then
July and there's basically no
precipitation along the west coast and
the other thing that's happening is that
Pacific subtropical high that setup shop
out here and the sinking air is
providing it for a very dry coast along
on the west here
ok so let's back up and talk about
what's happening in our part of the
world so in our part of the world you
know we're we're down hid downstream
mid-latitude cyclones they come ashore
here and they come and land and maybe
maybe they dumped some more
precipitation but by the time they get
to us it's pretty dry right so learn
they're kind of the rainshadow of this
whole area and so we have a pretty dry
January in February and March in April
and we can see the effects of that
Pacific subtropical high keeping this
whole area pretty dry and then here we
are in May in the east half of New
Mexico is actually starting to get some
precipitation because we're starting to
set up that unstable air that we call
Tornado Alley we've got warm humid air
moving in from that Gulf of Mexico we
occasionally get cold dry air coming
down from Canada they mix it up over
here produce lots of thunderstorms we're
seeing that kick off here and eastern
New Mexico is getting a little bit of
that now the mountains right through
here block that moist air from coming in
so this pool of dry air is protected
from this humid air from the mountains
okay so that's May June kind of the same
story
and then boom July something changes
right and what happens is we get our
monsoon circulation that's the next
lecture ok so I'm gonna just punt on
that for now but we go through our
monsoon season and then the monsoon
season kind of comes to an end and we
start to see the rebuilding of that
Pacific subtropical high you know the
effects the dryness here and then we get
into the winter months so we're actually
finally getting into this book
bitte and we're gonna get more into this
book in a couple weeks but we there's a
few pages that apply to us now so in the
introduction pages 10 and 11 there's a
section here on the difference between
weather and climate okay so we kind of
talked about that they talk about
climate zones and there's a map of the
world the major climate zones of the
world so based on everything we've
talked about right the ITCZ subtropical
highs but polar front all that stuff
there are zones in the world that have
similar climates and they they get names
if we're into this we're not going to
dig that deep but this map kind of shows
some of the different climate zones that
are set up because of some of the things
we've been talking about on the next
page so here they talks about layers of
the atmosphere in composition we talked
about that in the past the last lecture
was on atmospheric circulation there is
a section here in the book that has a
break break away view of the
circulations that we were talking about
and some basic principles of circulation
over here so it's a good kind of review
of what we talked about last time
you